so has it been how's rehearsals been
Nashville you guys are partying in
Nashville well
are you learning all the Pickler isms
now to be the thing that's pick it up
yeah yeah I love it she's hilarious she
has a good she's about you in the right
a little book cuz each day she probably
comes up about 20 different like little
you know languages it's pretty funny
they take be anything how does your body
held up from the rehearsing and any
injuries and has a stepped on your foot
yet no I don't know um it's been really
great I mean of course I'm working
muscles that I did not had so I'm so are
a little bit but that's I mean it's a
good thing I hope so haha
I thought money Beyonce 31 I love it are
you nervous for the live aspect they
getting me I've liked a serious but you
have done live I mean it's like that's
what I do though this is different I
mean I'm not a dancer I haven't been
doing this my whole life so I'm stepping
outside my comfort zone
it's a good thing yeah I mean I'm having
a lot of fun and Dericks great good
company she's doing great man it's it's
the blast she's she's definitely like a
natural going no bring it on no like if
she if I I was thinking about her
capacity like her legs when she whines
wishing news and I was man if you are
like a dancer like you know you train
and you can answer like she'd be
incredible she's amazing so that's my
job is to get her the incredible a short
like a week I know a short amount time
the whole profession thing going oh my
goodness well I did tell Wynonna which
I'm so excited that she's ready to show
- I got another country girl out here so
maybe between the two of us one of us
will bring that shiny ball back - oh wow
but dizzy that the this the votes are
gonna be split between country fans I
don't know I mean I'm to be honest I'm
really not a competitive person I just
want to have fun I've had a look at this
opportunity as an extracurricular
activity
the umeo like you that you're completely
has no idea what you were getting
yourself into when you when you sign up
for it or did you think you have to
after you know they did the announcement
that you know the cast and everything I
literally I went home that night and I'm
laying in the bed and I look over my
husband I'm like maybe it's too late is
it yep just have fun that's it okay
you're right I'm just gonna have fun
has he seen you rehearse yet no he
hasn't he hasn't he's coming in this
week so I'll be glad to get him here
have my love here so he'll be at the
first show all right well you guys have
been rehearsing the same she got all
right do it
nice